okay time for another movie review and
actually this time it's movies review
because they're because they're kind of
related yeah we're gonna do a general
overview of Prometheus and alien
covenant and the reason why we're doing
this is because in a few more days our
main show topic is gonna be kind of
zecharia sitchin ancient aliens Anunnaki
type program and that subject actually
kind of fits in with these two movies
yeah there's some there's some related
you have a DNA there yeah it's like
Ridley Scott telling you a Chariots of
the Gods time sorry yeah alright and a
lot of it is kind of borrowed from
zecharia sitchin type ideas and stuff
about the Anunnaki but we're not gonna
go in it's super a lot of detail we're
just gonna try to give an overview of
these two movies a lot of stuff when
they came out there were a lot of fans
that didn't like him and there was
mostly fans of alien they wanted to see
xenomorph stuff and a continuation like
it was an alien 5 and Ridley Scott's
going like no no we're not gonna talk
about that too much this is taking place
in the same universe as Blade Runner the
Alien franchise or at least the first
two aliens in the original old franchise
like alien and aliens also you know you
could you could say the movie soldier
which is that's a crustle movie yeah
contractually obligated soldier is you
know soldier is actually a story kind of
like space Rambo a badass guy from the
world of Blade Runner gets replaced by
replicant soldiers and that was the
original take on that movie I don't
think they actually got the license to
use the words replicant or anything I
don't I don't really think that it went
down that way but when they wrote that
script so I got a mess and crustle then
this is all part of the crustle sphere
yeah but anyway where do you want to
start with talking about these tomb well
I just kind of want to do a basic and
like you said I think it's weird because
both movies when they came out they made
a lot of money you know if they made a
very large profit seems like they were
pretty favorably received by critics and
fans although there were some complain
it's about plot elements you know things
that were unresolved or things like that
which I can see but in a way it didn't
bother me as much now I have to say that
Prometheus which came out in 2012 I
think a lot of people like you said
we're disappointing so like oh we wanted
xenomorphs II wanted this and that yeah
this like it had a little bit of fat but
Ridley Scott was kind of like well I
didn't want to just rehash it or make
the same movie again yeah and he kind of
wanted to explore some more of the
philosophical ideas yeah behind the
creation myths and things like that
alien 1 & 2 left you know left it out
there well where'd this damn spaceship
come from with all these eggs on it and
you know what do they call it the the
the space cowboy the guy who was flying
that ship the so called fossilized alien
being
what was that where'd that come from
well that's what these two movies are
about they tried to kind of like explain
that now in Prometheus a lot of cool
stuff was caught out a matter of fact
they filmed a lot of stuff for both of
these movies that was cut out by the
students to shorten them one and some of
them some of the stuff that they filmed
was for viral marketing some of the
pretend TED talks with the character
yeah and that was another great thing
about these movies is that there's kind
of like an expanded users mental mental
stuff it's outside of the movies and
some of it bleeds off into Blade Runner
20:48 2049 s give me 20 49 which is an
awesome movie I have that on that 4k
high-res blu-ray that we still can't use
because our TV isn't good but that
that's a fantastic movie if you haven't
seen the new Blade Runner and the old
blade of rudder you got to see those two
it all conda's blending together the
question this movie's kind of asking is
what does it mean to be alive
what is consciousness are these robots
alive are these humans alive well we
you'll see what I'm talking about where
do you go where do you draw the line
between AI and real intelligence because
you can kind of read into it from these
movies is that humans are AI - humans
are replicants of these engineers and
we're these engineers come from you'll
see
I'm talking about when you watch the
moon the thing I like about the themes
of both of the movies you can tell that
Ridley Scott was very influenced by
Greek mythology by Aztec mythology like
you know God's giving up pieces of
themselves to make humanity yeah and
things like that he was also very
influenced by Paradise Lost actually the
first Prometheus was actually supposed
to be called Paradise yeah and then he
decided no that was a little too on the
nose and then alien Covenant was
actually supposed to be called alien :
Paradise Lost so he kind of made it
explicit but they didn't end up calling
it that but that's what he originally
wanted to call it now there's a lot of
judeo-christian stuff going through this
too but the interesting thing like I
said about the Paradise Lost sort of
connection is that you can see the
character of David who is the Android
yeah he's almost like I don't want to
say fallen angel but like a dark angel
now the interesting thing about
Prometheus is that the whole theme of
Prometheus is the main character
Elizabeth Shaw she is a Christian and
she believes in God but she's very
excited by the fact that she has
discovered where the engineers where
these are our creators it's not like a
god it's not supernatural they're aliens
I love how Jenny can put all this into a
better context and I can I can't speak
about this movie in order in such an
orderly fashion
really good I understand the movie yeah
I understand but I take it piece by
piece
yeah each little scene I understand that
the symbolism is you know I understand
the symbolism of them there are whole
YouTube channels dedicated to these two
movies and a lot of [ __ ] to unpack and
there's a lot of stuff packed in there
and there was a lot of stuff that was
cut out yeah the original scripts have
leaked so I've had the original script
basically dictated to me from Prometheus
and had the studio not cut out a lot of
details it would have made a lot more
sense people complained this movie
doesn't make sense well it makes sense
it's just that some of it got cut out
and they're not the work for you and in
one scene one of the scientists involved
with the expedition puts down this
holographic cube that shows all these
holograms he's given the briefing to the
crew before the
mission if you look at the hologram it's
a Rubik's Cube
so Ridley Scott is already telling you
that this story is gonna be kind of like
a puzzle the story is gonna be talking
about a puzzle the puzzle of human life
and also the movie itself is like a
puzzle if you watch the movie you'll see
what I'm talking about but there's just
a lot of cool stuff in the movie and the
movie kind of reminds me of 2001 a Space
Odyssey where a bunch of stuff happens
it's not really explained to you you
have to kind of figure it out on your
own yeah which is another movie that a
lot of people bitching today bitching
aids that but it's a classic movie
prometheus though I mean we've seen it
several times we saw it in the theater
we might have seen it more than once in
the theater yeah you know we've seen it
I've probably seen it six or seven times
at this point and I have to say that
much like a David Lynch movie it kind of
like the more times you see it the more
things open up to you and you're like oh
yeah right because you really have to
pay attention to like all these little
details to be inferred and then it's not
expressed right and yeah that's what I
mean and so like I said you know so the
whole theme like I kind of like and I
think a lot of people bitched about this
when alien covenant came out you know
because they were thinking about oh they
wanted stuff from Prometheus resolved
and it wasn't yeah but in a way I kind
of liked the way they did that because
her Mathias in many ways it's sort of a
hopeful movie yeah um a lot of horrible
[ __ ] happens in it obviously but yeah
you know at the end of it Elizabeth
Shaw's I'm going to paradise I'm going
to where the creators that where the
engineers came from and I want to ask
them like what is it all mean and all
this others comfort go after we die
right so like I said this is a very you
know that's a very hopeful movie but
then alien covenant comes out and is
basically saying paradise is not what
you think it's going to be it'd be
something really really bad again which
is kind of something that is harkening
back to Milton and like I said that's
where I'm coming back to the character
of David yeah the interesting thing
about him is that he does not understand
why humans think it's so important to
find their creators because David has
the attitude of well you guys created me
and you guys are inferior
right yes you know I'm better than you
so why do you care I don't care about
you guys right yeah I mean so in a way
he's like a really good villain he
wasn't so villainous in the first one
well he was kind of but he did some
pretty shady [ __ ] you know his villainy
didn't really come out until yeah till
alien gave him the second one it's
implied that he kills Shawn as some of
these teams some of these people if they
had to see the movie they don't know
we're talking about yeah but I've
watched it over and over again and we
don't know whether or not he killed so
he may have been trying to save Shaw cuz
Shaw may have been infected by that
black goo when they pulled the damn
octopus out of her yeah I don't the
people in the audience like what the
hell they talking about yeah wait
creature when the audience came when the
squid creature was pulled out of her by
the the robot well I guess you say the
medical robot yeah that was in that sack
and it burst and fell back into her to
open a wound so she may have been
infected by the black goo now I don't
know whether or not I should tell the
code and the secrets of these tumor
lovely not I mean like I said we could
probably do kind of an overarching theme
of it but like I said for many years I
enjoyed not knowing all right and I had
to kind of find the right channels on
YouTube where it was all coalescing yeah
you know and I guys have figuring out
what what was cut out they were read the
scripts that leaked and kind of went
through all the theories of what this
movies actually about and they it's
actually crystallized to me and
basically what they're talking about is
it's Sakurai's hitchens Anunnaki chariot
to the god time pretty much it is kind
of like that yeah human religions that
we have on the earth now we're actually
spin-offs of an original tale that
happened between the humans and the
aliens or the things from heaven that
made them that we're actually the robots
that the gods made to kind of like
terraform this planet yeah that's
basically what what the deal was they
were trying to restore their planet
trying to restore their paradise and we
were failed experiments basically is is
what the deal was I will I will give a
couple of clues in the blu-ray if you
buy the blu-ray of Prometheus you'll
find out that
Weyland was friends with Tyrell Tyrell
made the replicants from Blade Runner
it's inferred from some files in the
blu-ray that Weyland knows how to make
replicas it starts making a lot of sense
why Vickers was calling him father and
why David was calling him father he had
created both of them he had on the ship
a robot and a replicant in charge of the
mission the movie makes a lot more sense
when you realize that Vickers is his
daughter but only in a certain sense
she's a replicant all right and that's
why there's so much competition between
the two now some people have tried
really knock Prometheus like well the
scientific crew they were all idiots
yeah they were idiots because they were
hired by Vickers and Vickers wanted the
mission to fail yes a lot more sensing
that light she got the bottom of the
background right yeah she went out on
purpose to get the worst people that she
could and the people that suspected that
maybe these hieroglyphs came from aliens
so that was Shaw and her boyfriend they
were taken on the mission to be used as
experiments had to be killed this is not
NASA doing this mission this is an
oligarchy doing this mission right and
he's there to steal fire from the gods
that's what Prometheus yeah stealing
fire from the gods was kind of a you
know that's an analogy but he's gonna
steal the secrets of how to create life
yeah he wants to be a God himself be a
God himself and to have eternal life and
only the creator's would know how to do
that and there's a deleted scene in the
blu-ray where Weyland confronts the last
of the engineers and asks for a turtle
life he's like who are you to ask for
some [ __ ] like this basically he ends up
he's like and make robots they made
these robots and they're better than
humans in any way and that then that
engineer freaked the hell out he didn't
want would you want your robots making
robots no you know and these Anunnaki or
these engineers have a different concept
of what God is the back story I don't
know if I should spill the backstory to
the engineers but the engineers are
trying to restore the power of creation
I'm just gonna put that they're trying
to save themselves they
had a couple of different kind of
mechanisms to do it a gold gu and if you
drank that you would break down and you
could see the planet and uh and you'll
see that in the opening scenes evidently
they ran out of that gold goo and they
went to a black goo and the black goo
was an artificial gold GU those of you
know what I'm talking about no talk
about that goo didn't work didn't quite
work it was like an evolutionary
accelerant and made you more of what you
were anything that came in contact with
the black goo just it just you would
evolve forward but Chi in a negative way
now the Xenomorphs and everything we're
kind of related to this black goo you
can kind of see eventually how this is
gonna go it has to do with robots and
what robots do with black goo but yeah
but that's that you know well until
that's what I mean when you get to alien
covenant as I said Prometheus was more
of a philosophical film yeah alien
covenant you can see how they tried to
meld the two things they still wanted
the philosophical element but they
wanted it to be more like the original
aliens like more of a horror action type
yeah the fella the problem with alien
covenant is that you had Ridley Scott
trying to complete this engineer out
iñaki story arc on one hand and I think
he was doing a good job and then you got
the studio's on the other hand said no
no no you got to put aliens in there and
you have to get these alien fanboys
going with the xenomorph action he's
being forced to kind of take it down
into the monster movie right at first he
didn't want to do that when they first
announced covenant he said there's not
gonna be Xena Morrison's yeah when you
see you it's kind of sick of it when you
understand the story and see what the
studio's made him drop and cut out of
there man it would have been so much
better had they just let Ridley Scott do
what he wants although honestly I
enjoyed covenant is I think you know the
the tonal kind of thing it didn't quite
work but I think overall it was a pretty
enjoyable movie I liked it when after I
saw it I liked Prometheus better yeah
but I still think alien covenant is a
good movie it still kind of explored the
same sort of themes and like I said I
liked that they took David in like a
darker direction because he's almost
he's gotten to the point where you know
he has he is himself a creation of
humans but he is better than humans any
knows that he's better and there and any
things are making him there in forcing
him to serve them right and there's
actually the the best scene like the
opening scene of alien covenant is like
a flashback to Weyland yeah and he first
makes David and you can tell right away
that David is already champing at the
bit like you know he's already just like
I'm better than you why should I do what
you want yeah and I think the cool thing
about that is that over the course of
the movie like in the time period
between the time line of Prometheus and
when alien covenant starts David has
developed the power to create things on
his own so he has basically become the
best human right now I actually read a
great and this and there's actually like
a lot of threads of kind of Frankenstein
and then yeah about human hubris trying
to you know become a god I read this
really really good quote in a in a
review of alien covenant where she was
talking about the character of David and
she's talking about the Paradise Lost
kind of connection and she says David is
a better Satan than Satan himself in the
alien universe the devil has evolved
thanks to humans creating him David
fatally has the ability to create
something Satan never had and he will
use that power only to destroy he
doesn't have any real need to rebel
against his maker since from the moment
he became sentient he knew he'd already
won both in the Alien franchise and in
the Blade Runner franchise there's a
theme of you are always better than the
thing that created you yeah and that
also stands true with humans humans are
actually better than the engineers that
scene was where David says that was kind
of cut out of alien covenant it's in
there somewhere okay it's in one I think
it's in a deleted scene somewhere but I
can I convey we kind of remember or it
was either/or it was either in a deleted
scene or it was in the original script
where he tells one of the crew of the
Covenant that the engineers were
actually kind of beastial that the
technology that they had was organic and
it was it had a lot of nanotechnology
involved in it and it was also um it was
also an analog technology and digital
had never occurred to them so they
didn't have computers and they didn't
have they couldn't make AI as we would
know it
they just made creatures yeah that was
their I ever seen AI and you know and
evidently they didn't first that those
ships were grown and they did have
evidently solar technology and that they
used solar power but evidently the the
personalities that the engineers had
were kind of beasts like they weren't
human like and in that way yeah they
didn't have legal systems if they just
want to kill you they did it they were
like that yeah wonder they didn't really
explore like I said and I think this is
something that a lot of people got
annoyed about when alien coming it came
out because they said well they wanted
to know more about the engineers and
things like that but like I said in a
way I kind of liked that in covenant it
was almost like it didn't matter well
cuz they're not gods they're just aliens
in covenant when Shaw and David show up
to that second planet that they called
paradise yeah and he drops all the
ampules on those beings that look like
the engineers yeah if you look at him
closely they're not engineers they're
not yeah they don't look exactly it was
another planet that they had seceded
they were kinda like engineers but not
really if you look at them side-by-side
they're very different and also those
beings that David wiped out were the
size of human of us yes they weren't big
they weren't big an engineer was twice
the size yeah they were like um and I
had exoskeletons yeah and he also didn't
have male and female gender yeah they
just they were all asexual they were all
male sterile males and the ones that
David wiped out you can clearly see
females in there yeah true and they were
wearing clothes there were clothes on
yes
yeah they were a normal size in the
deleted scene from Prometheus when the
engineer goes aboard the the lifeboat
I remember the light because it gets
ejected he sees a video of a little girl
playing violin and he's totally
mesmerized because they hadn't seen
female ya know gender you know yeah he
was kind of or children either or
children and computers and things
because okay I'm gonna go ahead and
spill a beam the engineers have lost the
ability to reproduce
but they could live for hundreds of
thousands of years and they were a
spacefaring type of race somewhere along
the line they got they came in contact
with some kind of an alien creature that
had impregnated one of them and it
bursts out of in this creature kind of
mated with the host and burst out of him
like an alien chestburster
and in the case with this engineer what
came out was an alien engineer hybrid
that was evidently a great being they
called it like their deacon or their
Savior and by its blood they were gonna
save their race which that sounds well
this thing comes out and evidently it
can speak and it's there a chance of
salvation to save their dying race and
they were using the blood of their
Savior they were drinking it in a
sacrifice to seed these other planets
which that's how earth was created but
evidently they had all failed with the
exception of earth and maybe another one
earth was a close one
but we were different than them though
they didn't like how we were so they
even took human children from their
mothers and took them back to paradise
where they came from to raise them and
they reinserted them back into the earth
to try to seed a good population that
wasn't warlike and they killed those
messengers one of those messengers
evidently they killed 2,000 years ago
yeah so what they're talking about his
space gene yes and 2,000 years ago when
we did that they decided to reboot life
hereby yeah they suck by dropping a new
black goo that they had made it was like
nanotechnology and it's because the
deccan that made that their Savior the
deccan what they call that made the gold
goo that you see in the first opening
scene of Prometheus because what that
one engineer drinks is gold and it's
yeah well they ran out of that so they
had to synthesize a replacement it was
this black goo and it didn't work it
wasn't quite as cold what did it didn't
quite work well now evidently according
to the scripts the engineer out of
prometheus that you see is the last of
them they all killed each other in a war
over him over mankind it was like a war
in heaven some of them wanted to drop
the black goo on earth and other ones
did
yeah that goes that little thing where
the crew of the Prometheus found found
them all dead and like they had battled
and they were dropping black goo on each
other yeah
and evidently there was a disagreement
between the engineers of whether or not
humans were their last hope for life in
the universe because you see they they
themselves didn't have to survive but
they were considering us their prodigy
they kind of considering us then but a
pale imitation of them in their opinion
which like I said that the relationship
of the engineers and the humans yeah is
analogous or parallel humans a replica
to humans and robots and and David right
so that's like the two threads that are
going through it well I'm like I said in
Alien Covenant the main development the
most important development is the fact
that David can now make things yeah he's
not now you got robots making stuff
right like he's no longer dependent on
his program and in the in the new Blade
Runner they're starting to hint at
replicants being able to reproduce so
yes and who are we to make to make any
judgment on who is a human yeah or who
is really alive or who is real are these
AI creatures are they real you know and
you know I mean these robots are they
real people do they have souls yes but
that's that's the question
these replicants do they have souls well
in the new Blade Runner they were like
what about these Holograms do they have
souls yeah you know so that's what
they're talking about what does it mean
to be real that's what I think I mean
that really seems to be Ridley Scott's
main theme and pretty much all of his
work all the extended universe yeah is
when it gets to a point where AI or a
robot is so good that you can't tell the
difference between a human yeah is it a
human is there anything that
distinguishes us yeah I mean I think no
right I don't generally believe in like
a soul per se yeah all this read all
these Ridley Scott movies in the Blade
Runner franchise the Blade Runner wanted
to alien 1 and 2 Prometheus and alien
covenant you got to see him I even would
want to throw soldier in there cuz it's
got cross all and that's that's the
Blade Runner Rambo yeah
played around Rambo it's kind of like
that yeah you like I like that movie
it's a good low-budget movie but yeah
like I said I mean both movies you know
they themes are epic yeah they really
are when you think about it yeah but
it's not spelled out for you it's not
for a lazy audience and I can see how
some people particularly alien covenant
where like I said they tried to combine
both of the things and it doesn't quite
work even though I still enjoyed the
movie you know and yeah I can see there
were accusations and they're the
characters did dumb things and stuff
like that but you know it's well the
several horror franchises in action
franchise yeah do dumb things you got
and the Studios one under a lot of
pressure because you have a lot of fans
from from alien to wanting this to be an
action shoot-'em-up yeah between
basically Marines and a bunch of yeah
that's not gonna happen in a Ridley
Scott that's what I mean and you could
you can't really win because you know
when Prometheus came out which was you
know really not like it's in the same
universe as alien and aliens but it was
a completely different animal it was a
different kind of movie then people
bitched about that but then when alien
covenant came out where it's like they
still wanted to continue that thread but
wanted to make it more like the old one
people bitched about that because they
were like well no we don't know what
happened with the [ __ ] and Prometheus
yes like you answered didn't answer the
question the stuff that was cut out of
Prometheus I think really would have
helped it I think because in the script
David could read all of the engineer
writing in the inside of the cattles and
in the script he told Shaw was what some
of that said and it's it was wild [ __ ]
about how the impure hat you know could
not enter into the sacred ground
for the blood of their Lord and it
sounds very Christian II yeah well they
didn't want that in you know all these
modern studios don't want any reference
just any kind of religion see they think
I needs to like it you know and I think
they didn't want they wanted to leave
that disclosed annuus basically what the
what the movie was about is that the
religions that we believe in and it goes
back to all those cave paintings and all
the ancient Egyptian religions and the
ancient Greek religious the Titans yeah
you know the time talking about the the
the they're talking about the engineers
yeah that all human religions were
basically mock-ups of what had really
happened between humans and beings from
the heavens it's awesome story which is
a cool idea cool
it's kind of you know the ancient aliens
theory is kind of a sad that's where
people get that that's where it is so it
alls gonna tie in I'm pretty sure that
Ridley Scott is getting all this from
you know stories about the Anunnaki and
zecharia sitchin and this is one space
Jesus and like I said you know on our
honor the gods writing all that on a
regular show which is coming up this
Tuesday we're gonna be talking about
yeah well tell Aryans and all that kind
of so we're gonna give you a heads up on
these shows first you know if you should
rent them Wrentham rent him an HD
they're beautifully well crafted movies
they're really really live if you
haven't seen him you gotta see him I'd
recommend seeing all six of them and I
did I recommend six yeah
- yeah go go see him the blade runner's
the two blade runner's and the for
aliens or alien wanted to and then
Prometheus and covenant you don't need
to see alien three and four there call
most like spin-offs and they're not that
good well yeah they're okay they're
alright movies but they don't really
have anything to do it on a larger they
don't have with a larger theme or the
theme of things which actually is one of
the things I enjoy about the alien of
Blade Runner universe is that a lot of
its interrelated you know a lot of them
share themes and yeah creation and
hubris and things like yes I like that
universe and like Rambo you want to
throw a soldier in there the guys that
wrote soldier wanted it to be a Blade
Runner Blade Runner Blade Runner stuff
right so that means it's in this - it's
just a cool action movie crustle I
haven't seen it you watched it without
oh [ __ ] we'll see it again I want to see
yeah okay it's good at the blu-rays good
I mean it's about like Riddick one okay
well I got like that me speller yeah
I'll check it out yeah alright so I hope
you guys enjoyed our kind of rambling
discussion about the themes of
Prometheus and yeah you can't really
cover it in all detail like I said just
watch the movies and then if you really
want to take each issue in detail they
got channels on YouTube that can explain
each scene in each issue so you're kind
of going into a into a fanboy world of
your of your own that kinds of / Memphis
and alien covenant Ridley Scott yeah and
they're all the Easter eggs and all the
Easter eggs that go into the Blade
Runner series cuz there is a bunch of
crossover oh yeah yeah alright so hope
you guys enjoyed that remember if you
like the show to like share subscribe
share on all your social media and tell
all your friends about us it really does
help out a lot if you'd like to
financially support the show that would
be very awesome also you can go to our
patreon page which is patreon complex 13
o'clock podcast or you can go to our
blog which is 13 o'clock podcast
wordpress.com and there's a link in the
sidebar to a PayPal account if you'd
like to make a one-time donation also
remember to check out our regular
episodes which come out every Tuesday
and our movie reviews which come out
every Friday we will see you next time
bye